you have no idea what's coming are you
ready the kardashian
the kardashian jenner ladies are ready
for their tv comeback fans are getting a
new sneak peek at their hulu reality
series called what else the kardashians
it's so exciting the latest promo
features kim courtney chris kendall
chloe and kylie and while we don't
actually see any footage from the show
the words on screen say it all
you have no idea what's coming
are you ready the kardashians
but there's more check out these
behind-the-scenes snaps shared on the
hulu show's instagram account we have
chloe getting her hair and makeup done
chris on her phone kylie cradling her
baby bump courtney making a funny face
on a golf cart and kim and kendall
striking a pose it's so crazy this all
follows the first look we got at the
kardashians on new year's eve happy new
year everyone now they still haven't
announced a series release date but
chloe told ellen degeneres this in
october either end of january uh early
february fast really fast so that's the
beauty of hulu we're streaming and we
get to have a much quicker turnaround
than previously and here's what we do
know after ending their e-reality series
keeping up with the kardashians in june
the fam started filming the kardashians
just a few months later in september at
the time kim shared this photo of a
microphone pack on her lap alongside the
caption day one just tune in because you
never know what's going to happen the 41
year old beauty mogul also posted a
screenshot from their family group text
and while it's unclear if it's directly
related to the start of filming it seems
kim appreciated the inspiring message
shared by her momager it makes me proud
as for chloe well she's stoked to share
her life on tv again we're really
excited they're here now in the back
shooting with us and we're so happy to
be you know up and rolling again and one
thing you can definitely expect to see
courtney and her now fiance travis
barker's love story i love it last june
a source told et that the blink 182
drummer is expected to make an
appearance on the kardashians hulu show
his kids may appear as well but not as
much as he will be featured of course
the musician is dead to 16 year old
daughter alabama and 18 year old son
landon we'll also see the couple's
over-the-top engagement courtney shared
a sneak peek at the footage on her
instagram story i love you
so while we wait to watch their dreamy
proposal on tv we know court's famous
fam is over the moon about their romance
i love their relationship like they've
grown so much together and have really
like made some amazing to think that
they've been neighbors and friends for
almost 15 years my neighbors for like a
decade and then all of a sudden yeah
they cannot keep their hands off of each
other i mean like
[Music]